hello there every so often on YouTube a
video pops up with the title Dead game
the thumbnail usually has a Derpy face
and a gravestone beside it or better yet
a red line which gradually goes down
declaring your favorite game is over and
you should move on so I wanted to figure
out what makes a game Dead what signs
can be seen and how they can be avoided
from fortnite to OverWatch from Fall
Guys to multiverses are they all really
dying games and who makes that decision
for online games like battle royales and
MMOs there's a single metric used to
determine how popular a game is
concurrent player numbers how many
players are playing this month this week
this day and even this hour and that
data gives us headlines like these
Marvel's Avengers has lost 96 of its
players since launch the end multiverses
has already lost more than 90 percent of
its players on Steam fortnite Pros are
quitting the game at an unprecedented
rate Destiny 2 records lowest player
count ever do headlines mean these games
are destined to die well no but for some
these headlines are the start of a real
decline a game is only dead when the
lights go out usually The Game's Twitter
account stops posting for months the
servers are then given a shutdown date
and the developers move on to something
new the latest two games to be
officially dead games are scavengers and
split gate we're ending feature
development of duplicate scavengers
never even made it to console R.I.P as
more games want to live forever and
constantly defy the life and death cycle
of video games let's look at the games
with their heads on The Chopping Block
games which I really enjoy which have
the label of dying game what can be done
to keep them alive alright then you're
with me
multiverses multiverses arrived in Early
Access in July last year a platform
fighter filled with legendary DC
characters and iconic Warner Brothers
properties it has fun mechanics with
every character owning their own own
unique set of moves and it was heavily
praised on release and openly discussed
in the same conversation as the daddy of
platform Fighters Smash Bros everyone I
knew jumped on to try it over 20 million
downloads in the first month alone
multiverses promised us the world with
ranked game modes coming soon new
characters regularly introduced and the
battle pass to keep a steady flow of
content to come back for many of us were
addicted it seems like multiverses was a
destined hit for years fast forward six
months and the Picture Tells a different
story currently the main issue with
multiverses is exposure I honestly know
players who forgot this game even exists
marketing is pivotal to maintaining an
audience right now the game's director
is the only official hype man and the
community is doing what it can to carry
things along I wish that was the only
issue but scratched the surface and more
appear an unreliable and laggy online
experience poorly defined hitboxes in a
fighter a lack of ranked mode a me
mediocre battle pass an overpriced
storefront and this really annoying dog
okay the last one the last one is just a
me issue sorry about that the thing is
multiverses isn't officially out yet the
reason the game doesn't know how to
Market itself is because we're still in
early access my fear is people won't
come back to see the finished article
it's such a shame too as the level of
detail and thought put into each
character and their move set is Simply
Sublime is Multiverse is a dying game
the stats and issues I've outlined say
yes but with the might of DC and Warner
Brothers behind it and the skill of the
developers the story isn't over yet
a game which has already fallen this
year is spell break an Elemental Magic
inspired Battle Royale the idea was
amazing and the first few games really
showed us that Magical elements combined
with BR worked released back in 2018
things looked promising but after four
years one main issue stood out the game
never evolved limited weapon pools no
real variety of choice spellbreak could
not offer content updates at the same
quality and regularity as its peers and
if I'm honest I think it released too
soon technically it was ready don't get
me wrong but the core elements of
gameplay had not been refined enough to
understand why people would want to keep
coming back spellbreak does hold the
honor of being the first game to ever
release on console and PC with fully
implemented cross play on day one and it
had 10 million players and for an indie
game I don't think that can be called a
failure a real question was why would
anyone play this battle royale over the
other countless battle royales on the
market so the cold hard res spell break
died was down to its competition and the
saturation of battle royales available
spellbreak is gone but not forgotten
happened again Marvel's Avengers is
officially halting all support and
delisting the game from Stars later this
year this one is much easier to diagnose
what happened compared to other games
the review scars for Marvel's Avengers
saw the game as mediocre at the very
best and as a live service which asks
players to log in each day it was a
complete failure in my opinion the
downfall was because of the core
mechanics quickly becoming boring the
cool stuff we did in the single player
campaign were non-existent in the online
portion repeating the same missions to
slowly improve gear fighting the same
enemies over and over using the same
Weaponry endlessly grinding the same way
day in day out Marvel's Avengers also
outlines a key difference about PVE and
PVP AI is predictable and only real
people in PvP matches can truly make
each encounter feel unique I'll miss
Marvel's Avengers but I think I may be
the only one foreign
OverWatch 2 you may be wondering why one
of the biggest games to ever exist is on
this list of potentially dying games
well I'll get straight to the point
OverWatch 2 should not be a sequel the
plan was to release a full PVE mode
alongside overwatch's iconic multiplayer
modes it all made sense the lore of
OverWatch is quite compelling the World
building the character design the core
game modes are all well made and
presented and that led to countless
players who enjoyed the world of
OverWatch but they don't like PVP game
modes you can't blame them who wants to
jump online to get stomped by other
players and then be targeted by their
own teammates in chat so by releasing a
PVE mode those players would come to the
game and spend their money but it never
arrived we are now told that OverWatch
will release portions of its PVE
campaign over the next year but wait
OverWatch faces more issues the removal
of its frowned upon loot boxes has seen
the introduction of a lackluster battle
pass and one of the most overpriced cash
grab star conference I've ever seen in
gaming on top of that OverWatch changed
McCree to Cassidy as the orgy character
was named after a Dev who took part in
workplace sexual harassment
allegedly the issues keep coming as the
new characters are part of the battle
passes essentially putting them behind a
paywall for at least half the season and
the cynical players who've been around
say that this is a Pay to Win mechanic
as it's regular scene that new
characters are deliberately made a
little bit too strong to incentivize
players to want to be them so if the
best character is only available through
the battle pass you're either gonna buy
the battle pass completely give up on
the game or become very cynical that
battle pass is a nest of poor decisions
this season one of the items from the
battle pass was taken straight out and
thrown in the star to be sold for real
money instead I kind of miss the days of
loot boxes OverWatch may not get the
play time it once did but it will never
be a dead game this month alone at least
23 million people logged on Dead game
not quite yet
game given the mantle of dead game the
game show version of Battle Royale was a
massive hit thanks to unbelievable
Creator support on platforms like twitch
and YouTube and by releasing on
PlayStation Plus technically it was a
free game and this came out at the time
when lockdown was a very real reality
for many of us but as the months rolled
on and the very limited number of levels
began to take their toll people began to
leave but unlike other games Fall Guys
adapted finally going free to play
across all platforms allowing Xbox and
switch players to finally play and the
numbers rocketed once again new content
arrived not much but there is some new
seasons arrived and in July last year
four guys had 50 million downloads 50
million and yet many people still call
this a dead game
and that brings us to Fortnight the game
which sees the most Dead game
declarations in my comment section I'll
be honest I do think fortnite's best
days are behind it in terms of player
numbers and I do expect more people to
play less every year but fortnite is far
from dying in fact it has a plan to stay
on top let's go through all the issues
we've outlined in this video so far to
see how it Compares marketing I think we
can all agree it's tough to avoid
fortnite when on social media
solid battle pass absolutely offering
the premium currency inside the battle
pass to buy skins in the store makes
buying them a no-brainer and on top of
that there's always something unique in
the battle pass every single time
frequent content updates well back in
the old days we had weekly updates and
they were amazing right now the same
can't be said but more often than not we
have two new items brought into the game
every single month competition fortnite
has fought to stay on top before
offering a free battle pass when Apex
Legends look to be the Battle Royale of
choice and epic regularly looks at their
competition and ruthlessly plans things
to overshadow them constantly they know
how to fight
and finally the one that really matters
genre fatigue this is an interesting one
we've been playing for five years
constantly and at some point people get
sick of being the last person to survive
Battle Royale is coming to the end of
its dominance cycle and once again epic
has a solution creative 2.0 A system
that allows players to build and create
the game mode they want with ease
essentially making the entire Community
games designers fortnite will break from
its shackles as a battle royale and
evolve into any genre imaginable
Minecraft and Roblox have shown the way
and fortnite have now seen the light and
that helps us sum up the video the
ultimate reason why Games die is because
we've all had enough and we move on to
the next big thing all games will die
but some Will Survive longer than others
I'm Adam you're awesome I'll see you
next time